[Musique]
un des premiers actes forts de notre
mandature a été la création d'un nouveau
groupe politique troisième au parlement
européen réunion en europe au centre et
j'ai l'honneur d'être vice présidents de
groupes politiques au titre du parti
démocrate européen dont j'ai la fierté
de porter les valeurs la solidarité
l'implication des citoyens une véritable
rôle social depuis un an nous sommes
mobilisés pour engager l'europe dans la
transition écologique
nous avons été le premier parlement a
déclaré l'urgence climatique et nous
poursuivons avec toutes les déclinaisons
du pacte vers la loi climat pour
atteindre la neutralité climatique en
la stratégie pour la biodiversité ou
encore la stratégie de la ferme à la
fourchette et dans toutes ces politiques
je continuerai comme depuis un an à
faire entendre la voix de l'océan un des
événements marquants est évidemment le
break site
c'est la première fois qu'un membre de
l'union européenne nous quitte
il nous faut donc dessiné une nouvelle
relation avec nos amis britanniques
une relation qui soit juste et
équilibrée pour les deux parties mais
l'union européenne se doit d'en pêcher
toute distorsion concurrence qu'elles
soient sociales fiscales ou
environnemental il y a un an nous étions
élus contre les ennemis ont de l'europe
pour montrer que l'europe saurait se
montrer efficace et agir pour les
citoyens aujourd'hui ces contraintes
très méchant virus que nous devons
renforcer ce combat pour plus de
solidarité solidarité financière d'abord
pour un plan de relance à l'échelle de
l'europe solidarité au plus près des
régions pour réussir la transition
écologique numérique et pour reconquérir
notre autonomie ni sanitaires et
industriels solidarité aussi et enfin
très important pour préserver les
démocraties et pour préserver les tables
industrie et souveraineté européenne
c'était des gros mots il ya un an
parlement européen et maintenant grâce
au travail que nous avons effectué tout
le monde est d'accord pour parler d'un
nouveau plan européen de stratégie de
développement qui soit vais
numériques innovants et en autonomie
stratégique car nous ne devons pas
dépendre des autres mais de nous mêmes
et donc tout ça c'est grâce à vous grâce
à la confiance que nous avait témoigné
un autre que nous allons continuer à
travailler sur ces domaines là qui sont
essentiels pour l'avenir de tous les
européens